in this video I want to talk about
covalent modification but specifically
the irreversible type because in the
last video I mentioned that there was a
reversible type of covalent modification
this one is irreversible
so irreversible covalent modification is
basically proteolytic cleavage
specifically of the zymogens so
proteolytic pro do comes from protein
lytic comes from like you know breaking
a bond basically this is just cutting up
proteins cutting up proteins right so um
and specifically of zymogens well what
is the zymogen a zymogen is an inactive
precursor of an enzyme so it is a
protein right but it's not an active
enzyme yet okay so it can be turned into
the active form by the cleavage of
covalent bonds okay now a simple way to
remember this is that zymogens xym comes
from enzyme gen to generate right so
these things generate an enzyme okay so
they are not the enzyme themselves but
they are the precursor the things that
we can become enzymes they can be turned
into the active form by cleaving of
their covalent bonds so the example that
the classic example is chymotrypsinogen
Hammel trypsinogen of course it ends in
a gin okay which basically means that
it's a zymogen okay
so it can be cleaved it's actually
cleaved twice to become it's completely
active enzyme which is chymotrypsin
specifically alpha count Winterson so
what's up with chymotrypsinogen um so
it's made and stored in the pancreas
okay and as far as its structure goes
its synthesized as one long polypeptide
okay it is one long polypeptide okay so
there's one polypeptide unit to it so
that it only has tertiary structure
right um
it doesn't have quaternary structure at
least not when it's an enzyme Majin form
right so actually drew that here one
long polypeptide right it's 200 it's
actually 245 amino acids long okay so
this is 245 this is how many amino acids
are this amino acid number one all the
way to 245 and it's held together or
there are five disulfide bridges okay so
this here is representative of the
desktop right bridges so there's 1 2 3 4
5 disulfide bridges that hold this
together but it's one long polypeptide
unit and only a story structure now once
it after has been made in stored in the
pancreas eventually it's going to be
released into this into the small
intestine once it's in the small
intestine what happens so once in the
small intestine it then cleaved by an
enzyme called trypsin trypsin is another
digestive enzyme so when it's cleaved by
trypsin the result is pi chymotrypsin so
here we take this long 245 pull amino
acid polypeptide excuse me and trypsin
goes ahead and cuts it and it
specifically cuts it between the 15th
and 16th amino acids so now we have this
this two essentially two polypeptide
chain right there still held together
though because this this disulfide
bridge is holding this chain to this
chain ok so so that is the first
proteolytic cleavage right here that's
the first proteolytic cleavage that
results in pi chymotrypsin now pi
chymotrypsin is active ok
specifically it's active in that it
digests itself ok which I which I'll get
into in just a second so pi chymotrypsin
catalyzes self cleavage to give alpha
chymotrypsin which is the fully active
digestive enzyme so from here T once we
have pi comma trypsin it actually
catalyzes the cutting of itself ok it
use itself and then it actually gets rid
of the 14th and 15th amino acid residues
and the 148th and 141 440 seventh and
148th amino acid residues as well so
this thing here was already cut by
trypsin but once that happens this whole
thing can actually cleave itself so when
it does that it pulls off these two
residues here 14 and 15 it knocks them
out so there's actually a serine and an
arginine residue but notice this this
these two chains are still held together
by this disulfide bridge here because
that's also a covalent bond but notice
here that between the now all we have is
146 149th as far as the 147 148 amino
acid were cut out by pi comma trypsin
they were threonine in an asparagine
residue but notice that this chain is
still held to this to this chain by this
disulfide bridge here so this portion
here is called the Alpha chain or cement
the Alpha chain the a chain this is
called the B chain and this is called
the C chain so now this whole thing is
called alpha chymotrypsin which is the
active the fully active digestive enzyme
which can go through and actually both
you know help you in your small
intestine as for our digestion of all
heads of different macromolecules goes
okay hmm but uh why why do we care about
this first of all the whole idea is that
the cleavage of this enzyme right once
we've cut off these amino acids they're
not going to be formed back together
once you cut them out that's
irreversible okay but um this cleavage
is important to recognize that this
cleavage effects the activity of this
enzyme initially it was this inactive
precursor crime-lab trypsinogen but once
we cleaved it once it becomes active for
a certain reason that we cleave it again
and it becomes fully active so what is
the moral of the story the moral the
story is quite simply that what we did
was change the primary structure right
we change the linear sequence of amino
acids right so what happened here is
that the changes in the primary
structure resulted
and changes those changes that looks
like charges let me clean that up
and changes in a tertiary and even
quanta nary structure right and that
that change in structure was necessary
to change the function specifically it
went from the function was initially
inactive had no function right to
becoming active right so the change in
function is this idea of activity right
so here we change the the primary
structure and that's going to change the
way it folds and we even made it so we
add more than one polypeptide units we
made add into this despite chymotrypsin
in this alpha comma trypsin now have
quanta nary structure because they have
multiple subunits okay so that's sort of
a wrap up about irreversible covalent
modification specifically using the
example of how much trypsinogen one
thing I wanted to just write up here is
that here this was the second
proteolytic cleavage okay to result in
this active enzyme so I hope that was
helpful and I'll see you guys in the
next video